everyone Dayton oopsie good evening
everyone I'm Tammy my name is Mary Hamm
and I like ham our first story comes
from Gloria Borger Gloria Borger has
passed away now I'm not supposed to give
my opinion but this is so sad papi
Gloria was found dead in her apartment
we don't know yet who is responsible but
we do know that I was the last person
seen with Papa Gloria alive let's have a
moment of silence for Papa Gloria next
news
our next story follows YouTube YouTube
tyranny see what no way that can be
right
what did YouTube do this time they gave
a shout-out to SS sniper world ok not
that big of a deal this is the future
Sniper Wolf is here to share some of the
craziest vending machines all around the
world
PewDiePie had this to say oh I didn't
show up cuz I Oh YouTube's main some
people were upset about this saying that
this channel plagiarizes click big
articles like BuzzFeed every day without
citing a source promote channels that do
research and write their own material
please now to be fair this is not on so
Sniper Wolf this is more on YouTube I
mean I can't really fault anyone for
making low quality content except ham
news I do research goddamn E and I'm not
upset at Sniper Wolf ok I don't even
care that she got to meet Keanu Reeves
it doesn't really bother me at all
remarking and it doesn't even bother me
that she's been on the trending page two
days in a row I don't even have any
opinions so it would be literally
impossible for me to care next news we
have an update on the TPU versus face
drama now this is the hottest drama that
has ever dropped the T foo is suing face
claim oh my god
honestly why did anyone care now T foo
said release the contract please
but faze clan please release the
contract and then phase client be like
oh we are releasing the contract and
then fake-face Plan B like okay we're
not gonna actually release the contract
we're just gonna make a video multiple
different versions of contracts whoa
careful there buddy you're showing a bit
too much information
Wow thanks for releasing the contract
now we can go through all of it this is
great thank you
careful not to show too much just put
the contract out there they're crazy
2018 oh my god there's so much
information we didn't know if he wanted
more monthly salary we sent him a deal
that was gonna pay him seven figures a
year why do they always do that they
always take seven figures it's in 1
million whenever someone says seven
figures that means a million it doesn't
mean anything else seven figure oh a
million so they address the allegations
that face is taking money out of the
code T few stuff which apparently is a
lot of money into the Fortnight purchase
code thingamajigger we've seen a little
miscommunication in terms of community
understanding about in-game items and
what that might mean and what that apply
to let us be very on the record right
now that has nothing to do with support
of creator coach T P was signed in April
of 2018 while epic announcement
supporter created in October of 2018 so
they're basically saying it was
impossible for us to take money out of
it because you know they would have had
it in their deal if this contract
happened after they announced this
support a creator program you know you
know damn well they would put something
in there but they're saying that they
wouldn't do that
I
I kind of doubt on that when it became
clear to us that his Puran I've never
seen more private texts in my entire
life than these past three weeks every
one is just aa private text I will put
that in a video when it became clear to
us that his pure intention was really
just to leave that's very difficult
so they address the criticism that face
been getting because T P obviously wants
out of this contract why can't you just
let them him and they say this oh why
didn't you just let him out we are fans
much more of a debt than that because
our fans have invested their time and
their effort and their care and their
love into the relationship that we
created with T foo to kind of argument
is that it's for the fans guys they're
just looking out for the fans so they
want to preserve this relationship that
they have between the fans and face
Klein and Teague but Teague clearly
wants nothing to do with favs claim so
what kind of relationship are you
preserving there am I am I am I cavemen
dummy dumb I don't get it what's the
argument and for us to just drop him
solely because he wanted out I don't
think anybody can rationally claimed it
that would have sat well with our fan
base or frankly the culture of hit
gaming and relationships in general if
we were to just drop him the culture and
the relationship of gaming in general if
they drop him would be hurt what the
are you talking about that culture
is ruined because you didn't want to let
him out TV who said that I want to make
it clear that I tried multiple times for
multiple months to get out of this
contract no one was blindsided by
there's no one this relationship is
publicly broken how do you apply this
argument it doesn't make any sense I get
it from a business standpoint and I
totally get that they want to
renegotiate with TV you to keep him
signed that's obviously better for face
and they I understand that they built
this relationship that they need to keep
intact the contract actually did leak
and I showed it in my life's video
because Brad put it in but I hadn't
actually seen it so I didn't get a
chance to react to it because it
happened as the video went up and the
split was between phase and Tipu 80% in
favor of phase plan between brand deals
and then brand deals brought in by by T
few so he wasn't exclusive but if he
brings in the
randal he still has to pay them 50%
okay appearance fees 50% okay well I'm
just not gonna do any tournaments or
like public places then and tournaments
they take 20% damn what a great deal wow
I don't understand what if you want to
get out of this contract
now the cherry on the cake here is that
if he wants to leave or it gets out of
the contract
gamers shall be prohibited from playing
video games publicly online or in live
tournaments or professionally for a
period of six months I don't understand
why T few wants out of this contract it
makes no sense at all
what the Frick a lot of Frick's I don't
get it at the end of the day t for you
is a dummy dumb dumb for signing this
contract and face Klein is a dummy dumb
dumb for having this contract to begin
with it's a weird situation where I can
understand both sides
I understand T few from not wanting to
renegotiate when you're already in a bad
situation
but it also sounds like face gave good
deals to T few and good as a way to
compromise from this situation I think
it is interesting that T few spoke up
I'm curious if other people will as well
other people maybe are stuck in these
similar contract cuz otherwise I don't
think we'll hear anything about this
anymore because now both parties that
kind of said there's until there's some
legal development and whatever that's
gonna be it's gonna be hit hard I think
unless they settle outside a court T few
has now changed his fades Klan logo
threw spongebob Squidward
that's not squid or that's Patrick idiot
next news rest in peace social blade
YouTube just famous social blade
everyone YouTube announced that they're
changing the site to round out the
subscriber numbers it will no longer
show the specific number of each
subscriber it will round it up currently
all craters with over thousand
subscribers get their subscriber cone
displayed differently in different
places on YouTube and for the sake of
consistency they are changing this so
YouTube for example on their channel
says 15 point blah blah blah
it will now just say 7.20
instead of four thousand three hundred
four point three and depending on how
high subscriber count you have or how
low subscriber count it will round it
out differently so if you have low
subscribers it will it won't just show
nothing or whatever and this goes up
until a thousand and I think that's a
reasonable number at least to round it
off off but people were very unhappy
with this saying this is just annoying
I'd rather see the number go physically
up lul nobody once states I have a great
idea youtube listen to your creators
this also means the end of these flare
TV like live streams with the subscriber
counts going up and down because that
will no longer function then YouTube
will no longer give that information and
that was confirmed on Twitter as well I
think there's a couple things to note
here when YouTube said consistency I
thought they meant initially like other
websites have consistently like that
like Twitter shows the same way they
round up there's the numbers and same
with Instagram they round up the numbers
so I thought our consistency across the
internet but it no its consistency
across their website but I think most
people understand that this isn't just
because of that it's also to end these
sort of live subscriber count' drama
battle dwarfs or whatever you want to
call it we just clearly become a
phenomenon that's a word and of itself
that maybe I had a little bit part of
having something to do with maybe just a
little I think especially after this
Tati versus James situation where James
Trotter literally lost millions of
subscribers largely due to these live
streams that went on die showed the
subscriber camp it got it so popular and
and then I mean at the end of the day
James Charles pretty much came out on
top but he still lost so many
subscribers from it which I don't think
he has recuperated yet so it's
interesting regardless what YouTube
decided to do by this and and I don't
know it's rich for me to talk about this
because obviously I benefited from this
but I don't see this is that bad of a
thing I think in general people are
misplaced with YouTube and they want a
positive change I think YouTube
desperately needs a positive change for
the website something that people will
go wow that's some cool
I like that because right now it makes
it impossible for you to to announce
anything that isn't positive like fixing
the sub count system gaining fixing the
fixing this copyright system
nobody YouTube's changing something that
no one wanted basically brah
next news what forty thousand videos
tell us about the trending time this
YouTube recalled coffee break made a
video exposing the trending tab I'm
trying to understand what does YouTube
want from from us aspirated a clip from
the show the view that has 10,000 views
is not trending but it's number three
trend that's when you start to think oh
this is real I want to show you a clip
from the trending tab and as you can see
all of the videos don't seem to be made
by Creative bra now YouTube has
responded on this already Susan in her
promises for 2019 I don't know if that's
what it's called
I did say that at least half the videos
in trending will come from youtubers so
they are already implementing changes
for the training tab to benefit creators
which they've been largely criticized
for but I think what this video really
showed really well in this study that
coffee break did it's just visualizing
how it is right now so basically they
took data from 40,000 videos but data
40,000 entries a lot of my reason for
doing this is I want to answer the
age-old question is YouTube biased
towards traditional media I mean yes I
think generally youtubers has been seen
as something unsafe you know you can't
rest assured that every youtuber isn't
gonna be consistent with what they put
out there in terms of sparking
controversy and I think maybe I am a
testimony to that and generally
traditional media is a lot more safe
than that and that's why they're biased
towards it I mean I think that's
basically it but regardless them getting
on training how many views they needed
to get on trending and then we have so
the way the graph works is that it shows
average views before trending and number
of training videos Lele pons she seems
to have trended about ten times on the
training tab and she it took her about
four million views on average to get on
trending go
10 times ok so that's how to read this
so what do we find who do we find with a
lot of times on trending the answer is
overwhelmingly traditional media
traditional media as in ESPN as you can
show Jimmy Fallon Jimmy Kimmel Stephen
Colbert Netflix MBA a CNN box brunt
almost all late-night or like
traditional meat like the most
mainstream of mainstream media is who we
see over represented on trending over
and over and over again
and I want to stress this is not due to
the fact they're getting more views than
these other youtubers right because then
they would be up here for example if
Logan Paul's barrier to trending is
about 11 million views then no matter
how much he uploads he's a lot less
likely to trend frequently didn't
someone like ESPN who's barrier to
trending is on average about five
hundred thousand views eighty four brah
you know I always thought of the
threshold theory of like okay well could
Logan Paul gets consistently high of you
so you shouldn't need that much he would
have to actually get a lot higher abuse
to trend but eighty four something else
caught my eye
PewDiePie I know that guy his training
data is super interesting because he
trends all over the world yet he barely
trends in the US now here's where I tell
you that we don't just have the US data
set we have all these other countries
too and when you look at those countries
PewDiePie is crushing it everywhere
except the us even in non-english
algorithm it's bizarre though you got
now YouTube is mentioned for some time
that they have human moderators perhaps
he gets blocked most of the time perhaps
maybe but how do you test that I decided
to look at other controversial creators
too I don't think you need to test it he
then compares the stats with Canada
because it's similar this is because
Canada is operating in the same time
zones they have similar cultural
interests and they also speak English
now all of these controversial creators
are extremely popular and have some
level of swearing or edginess to them
and this is what I found on the US side
many of these creators aren't trending
at all or if they
are trending it's once or twice and
that's it for comparison here's the
Canadian side Oh 45 that means 45 times
someone at YouTube went PewDiePie get
him out of here
PewDiePie get him out of here PewDiePie
get get him out of here oh my god that's
amazing what else do we got the only
thing that makes up for it is maybe the
idea that America had moderation at this
point and maybe just maybe now he points
out the hypocrisy of the fact that a lot
of traditional media is actually very
edgy I moved on her like a venom cook
but I couldn't get there that's clearly
not what it's about it's not about
edginess is what YouTube deems save
content at least I haven't tested that
theory but I wonder how 44 of my videos
like what were those videos that were
deemed unsafe if that was the case
rename it sponsor tab there problem
solved just delete the trending tab
please I'm sick of hearing about it
what's the point it's just making people
pissed off like either make it
completely fair then again they they
have to the thing is if YouTube doesn't
censor the training tab there will be
articles written about how YouTube is
showing on this front page of YouTube
these bad content you know this is more
media attacks coming to YouTube if that
was the case how long is this video I
didn't realize it's gonna be this
goddamn long I have so much more to
cover here on PO news keep watching but
we have one more news I'm sorry whoever
has to edit this video it's God awfully
long but chaos I just got cancelled and
I need to put that in the title because
that's gonna bring more people in they
GK's eyes brother six minute video
called by where he calls out ksi his own
brother so apparently this is a concept
now where someone exposes someone that
they are close to in a 40-plus minute
video showing a private texts and making
the other person lose subscribers I mean
ksi is losing
subscribers now now they GE frame says
he he doesn't want this to happen and
he's just trying to stand up for himself
apparently a lot of people see him as
the bad guy and this is him showing I'm
not actually the bad guy and I don't
even try and follow the dead Guk side
drama that's been going on with all the
disk tracks and bla bla bla I never seen
dad yes the bad guy so I'm not sure
exactly who he's addressing here
probably ksi fanboys which mine probably
won't be changed regardless of this
video also let's not forget about the
dark place they made a new O's in a dark
place it just put me in a dark place
dark place in a very very dark place why
do all these people go to the range
without my permission
it's old video to me just seems like a
little brother not being feeling
recognized by his brother I couldn't
explain cuz I have done nothing but
support my brother
everything I've supported him with his
music
JD addresses a lot of the drama that's
been gone on between them behind the
scenes of the diss track talking about
how he was actually hurt by a lot of
things that went down and talking about
the drama that happened between
Christmas apparently there was something
that happened and he wasn't actually the
bad guy I cannot be bothered to get into
it I am don't care about the research I
give up okay it seems to me like haze I
maybe isn't the most compassionate
brother and a lot of history haver he's
kind of put towards Isis Panther and
they G maybe is a little more sensitive
than your average person it's just the
bits of banter please digi this is just
blunt but it also seems like a lot of
stuff went too far between them but here
we are private stuff in the public eye
very fun very interesting now it did
seem like this video actually swayed a
lot of people's opinion I used to
dislike you watching this video is
relatable I misjudged you without
knowing your backstory I wish you the
best day Jean it sort of became
overwhelming support for JD in this
video I guess now we can expect a 45
minute video from ksi addressing this
whole thing and another more back and
forth with private matter
that I don't even know I also feel like
this whole thing they already have a lot
of drama in the public eye so I can't
really be too critical about this whole
concept but it's just like god damn it's
another one it hasn't even been a week
has it it's under the last one Jesus
Christ that's it for this week's pew
news subscribe ring the bell
subscribe again and ring the bell three
more times and that's it I'm Mary ham
the most likeable and top voted person
by what you never played to / simulator
you know it's fun right I'm not supposed
to give my opinion but give it a try and
then you can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay I'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]